young and I had to find out a festival
so there he is asked about the drag
queen stuff he says I was young and I
had fun sue me for having a life
oh is your mother
guys
was your mother at the World Trade
Center on 911 is related to the fact
that Santos has told two different
stories about when his mother died I
love your guy who keeps following me and
plays fourth life I take with him
all right so then he gets himself into
an elevator here's a nice one cbs2
talked about this they are now as a
matter of fact just introducing him as a
disgraced Congressman which I have to
tell you I love we begin with breaking
news tonight disgraced Congressman
George Santos he's been he's been in
office a week and they're already
referring to him as disgraced
congressman